nous voilà donc dans le sud ouest de la
france on les connaît pas s'il était si
facile à trouver qui serait pas vraiment
super secret ce spot nom
pierre veut bien notre guide jusqu'à un
bras du lac isolée au milieu de la forêt
au fond c'est parti du lac il ya une
maison parfaitement intact
c'est indiqué nulle part
c'est loin mais je vous promets ça en
vaut la peine
nerveuse
après on va à new york commenter les
images et dès qu'on atteint 2 millions
de vues va direct se marier dans une
chapelle de vegas
la visibilité est plutôt bonne on
atteint le premier plateau à 10 mètres
de profondeur
on y est
j'avais oublié à quel point les gens
étaient superstitieux parisse
et voilà
dit comme ça
tout ça non
la neige